how would you describe a modern woman
she kind of done it for you yeah and
like nowadays it's like
like how would you describe girls your
age like typically General
it should be easy
how old are you materialistic um 21 okay
materialistic
outside that's like outside
active
what's the best word to use gone
honestly that
um
maintenance is a big thing as well
Nell's hair all of that makeup
I can't lie I'm even speaking by myself
right now
the truth will set you free not me I
could come over and do makeup on calm
but there's certain like in this
generation some people can't not do that
like they always I'm saying in terms of
like okay cool like you're describing
the Modern Woman yeah but okay let's
move it on to in terms of how they
interact with men you interact with us
like we're talking clubs like they see a
guy with nice car free ride home not
really thinking about the guy
there's that stuff there's oh there's
guys there there's the rich ones let's
go get drinks like I know some people
that will be saying like
we can go there's some girls that can go
to
a club or whatever with maybe one pound
and they could come out with a hundred
so you got like I'm saying I'm being
very rude about it like pretty people
don't even come out they won't even go
to the club with a pound they'll go
empty empty purse yeah lift home more
money pretty privilege is a roofing one
of the one of the guys in the friend
zone will drive them to the club yo
puppy I wanna go to the club with my
friends can you drop me there yeah yeah
thinking he's getting somewhere he ain't
getting nowhere bro you're actually
delivering her to other man
okay cool like yeah I agree with you I
agree with you do you do you think that
a little like women your age are quite
selfish
they can be not from what you described
kind of like selfish materialistic I
think the girl the girls are for the
girls at the moment like it's kind of
goes off for the girls girls are there
and girls are here like girl power in it
therefore we're deaf against each other
at the moment like against each other
yeah men are trash all this but we'll
still do what we have to do for these
men but how are the men against the
girls in your age group how are they
against them
[Music]
each other
so nowadays well from my like male
friends and stuff they'll always feel
like they were being used
or who's being used the guy is being
used by a girl but they'll ask me oh
what do you think about this and I'll be
like I have to keep a buck with them
they're not interested like only because
I'm a girl I've seen it I've been around
girls so with my male friends I'll be
completely honest with you they're not
interested so if you continue that's on
you but you're not gonna get how the how
are the guys
um like against the girls then
in what way
I think they just don't like how we are
now like how girls are now but so but
but from what you've said
you've basically said that girls are
using guys and don't care about guys and
they don't even like them
and then the guys are basically not
liking that that kind of behavior so
it's not really the guys and girls are
against each other as the girls are like
basically bad behaved and the guys don't
like the bad behavior from what you've
described
yeah but yeah I feel like we're creating
a lot of villains so then
yeah there's just a lot of trashy guys a
lot of trashy girls and it's just back
off
and it's just yeah that's where you
there's not that many relationships but
where there are ones you know
Valentine's day you will see them being
exposed that are talking to this person
this but it's just my generation is just
long black it's long no I hear that all
right cool what do you think how would
you describe a modern woman you kind of
did it already but yeah a little recap
she does what she wants she doesn't care
what people would say she sleeps with
the entire football team not caring what
people would say she move abroad
throughout the country if it's necessary
she's independent and a free spirit
yeah would you like would you two um
describe yourselves as more than women
yes yeah
did you sleep with the whole did you
sleep with the whole football team no
yes but I wish
listen she was stuff for a box leave
your music leave your movie
what about you do would you describe
yourself as a mother woman
I mean you got you got that make up you
got the nails yeah I feel like in terms
of the look and all that I do but I know
me as a person
I think like my mom and what makes you
what makes you traditional like I'm just
for the hope that I like the whole idea
of being like a woman to a man like
doing what you have to do for a guy like
I like that idea of it like I do like
being having someone that's more
dominant having someone that can tell me
like don't do that like this is gonna
happen if you do that or like and I feel
like only a man can do that for me like
so you you like the idea of a guy being
an authority above you I'm Your Leader
your captain
I'm not gonna lie I do even though I'm a
very dominant female like I know I don't
need a man
do you do you go to parties a lot
there you go no not a lot a lot that's
that I'll be capping if I said a lot a
lot but I'll be going partying so I ever
can I ask you a question is your mom
from the UK yeah
um I was just wondering like
traditionally because I've just found
that a lot of people you said dude your
mom's mindset so when people say that a
lot of times they're not from the UK but
no um no so why why would you dress like
a modern woman if you feel like you're
traditional well it's not like mixed
marketing because like I'm a confusing
babe what I'm saying like so so if you
want to if you wanna if you want a
traditional guy and he's like let me
find some me a traditional wife oh I'm
confused with me right but I'm saying
like then you might not get the right
type of guy because if you if you
portray one thing he's gonna he's gonna
think that's what you are but right now
I don't personally feel like I'm looking
to be someone's wife okay I know I know
it sounds mad but I'm young back I want
to live my life obviously not sleeping
around the whole football team like
that's not just that's not my idea
but I do want to live like I want to be
able to say stories like when I find my
man this
what kind of stories man you're gonna
say stories
because I went to Dubai and I met this
guy then I went to Brazil I met this guy
that's not everything
else can I ask my mom I want to ask her
about something real quick mom um what
stories do you like telling us because
you got you got married at 21 right 21.
when you you your first kid at
we don't want to talk about that
First Kid at 18. yeah so she had her
first kid at 18 21 what stories do you
like to talk about
the ones of Our Lives I mean and that's
what I think the fallacy is is that you
have to have those stories alone and we
have seen all 50 states my kids have
been to
I don't know how many countries a lot
we've done we've absolutely lived a wild
ride and it wasn't you know there was
many many years we didn't have any money
so it wasn't about money it was about a
decision to live life and to live it
holy and fully and I just happened to
have babies strapped on my front and on
my back and usually in my belly so it
was why why do you think we have this
like mentality that like your life is
over when you have a family you can't
have these crazy stories once you have a
family because I think that our society
tells them that I think we have a
society that hates children truly and I
think that
um that I think women think that they
have to look bad after they have kids
and and I think they think that they
can't live their lives after they have
kids and I can tell you all of it's hard
like it's not easy but I've lived very
well I you know life is good and and I
have a herd of kids
truly I think I think a lot of it boils
down to like women kind of just want to
go and live some kind of music video or
something like some music video or
something or Instagram explore page they
want to do everything in every square of
that explore page bro and it's just
unrealistic bars
all you're going to do is rack up
mileage and gather high body count
that's all you're going to be burnt out
but you can really you can do all of
those things if you get married and you
are working together toward those things
two people are better than one so you
can make but also financially talking in
different times like let's say if you
have a seven night children those days
you need a high income that I can tell
you that most of the time we had no high
income it was completely the opposite
but we work hard it it doesn't it's a
fallacy that it takes a lot of money to
raise kids it's a I don't believe it I
lived it I don't believe it as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible